نقلت القناه الثانيه عش الاسرائيلي عن
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يو اف جالانت قوله
ان من يتحدث عن ضروره السيطره على غزه
عسكريا لا يعرف عمق المشكله واضاف جالانت
وفقا للقناه الثانيه ع الاسرائيليه ان
السيطره العسكريه الدائمه على قطاع غزه
تعني تفضيلها على جبهات اخرى اكثر اهميه
وراى الوزير الاسرائيلي انه يجب تكريس
قوات الجيش لمهام في قطاعات اخرى
هي على وشك الغليان وخاصه في لبنان والضفه
الغربيه معنا من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام الياس جديد التطورات وما الذي
يفهم من هذه الخسائر التي تقع في صفوف
الجيش الاسرائيلي لا سيما في شمال القطاع
والذي قال انه حقق فيه
اهدافه
بالفعل اعداد الجنود والضباط الذين جرحوا
في الساعات ال 24 الماضيه بحسب بيانات
الجيش الاسرائيلي بلغ 26 عسكريا هذا
بالاضافه الى ثلاثه من الضباط والجنود
الذين قتلوا في معارك شمال وجنوب قطاع غزه
واذا ما اخذنا بعين الاعتبار اعداد الجنود
الذين جرحوا على الاقل في الاسبوع الاخير
بحسب بيانات الجيش الاسرائيلي وصل الى عدد
يفوق ال 120 عسكريا اسرائيليا سواء كان
ذلك في معارك شمال او وسط او جنوب قطاع
غزه وهذا يعني بان المعارك العسكريه ما
زالت على اشدها حتى لو ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قلل من اعداد جنوده في صفوف
الاحتياط وسحب وحدات من المدرعات
والمظليين والوحدات والالو الاخرى التي
عملت في الاسابيع والشهور الاخيره في قطاع
غزه لكن واضح بان المعارك ما زالت على
اشدها حتى في المناطق الشماليه التي قال
الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه انتقل فيها الى
المرحله الثالثه من ناحيه العمليات
العسكريه واحد ال الجنود الذين قتلوا
واعلن عنهم ضمن الثلاثه هذا النهار ايه
كان قتل في معارك شمال قطاع غزه واثنان
اخران في معارك الجنوب وهذا يعني ان
المعارك في المناطق الشماليه ما زالت تكبد
الجيش الاسرائيلي خسائره فادحه بالارواح
وفي العتاد وهذا كان واضحا وملموسا على
الاقل في اليومين الماضيين حيث كان شمال
قطاع غزه يشهد معارك ضاريه كنا شهودا
عليها في جباليا وفي بيت لاهيا وفي بيت
حنون وفي احياء مختلفه من مدينه غزه
تحديدا الضواحي الجنوبيه منها الجيش
الاسرائيلي حتى في بياناته هذا الصباح
يشير الى استمرار المعارك العسكريه في
المناطق الشماليه ويتحدث عن ما يقول بانه
قضى على مسلحين فلسطينيين خلال عمليات
عسكريه في هذه المناطق بالاضافه الى
المناطق الوسطى التي كانت ما زالت حتى
صباح هذا اليوم تشهد غارات جويه
وقصفاً وفق التقديرات العسكريه ووفق
التقارير العسكريه الوارده من هناك تشير
الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي اقام استحكامات
عسكريه واقام حواجز وان اهميه هذا اللواء
هو منع الفلسطينيين من العوده الى منازلهم
او ما تبقى منها في المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه على اعتبار ان هنالك تقديرات
تشير الى ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يحاول ان يستثمر ذلك كورقه ضغط
على المقاومه الفلسطينيه في اطار اي صفقه
لتبادل الا شكرا جزيلا لك الياس كرام
مراسلنا من غلاف غزه